there's been a volcano erupting for the  last 94 years almost continuously every  hour santiaguito is in Guatemala its  base is actually the second largest city  known to the locals as shayla or  quetzaltenango we think that there is a  continuous magma supply at depth that's  feeding this volcano and so you can  imagine that the magmatic system is  clogging up roughly on an hourly  timescale  and as that pressure increases your ups  in what might be a lava flow or a small  explosion very rarely are there major  explosive eruptions that might cause an  imminent threat however they do occur  this volcanic rock when it gets erupted  in it basically goes right over their  farm so all of that hard work and effort  is lost within you know a second  volcanic climates are really beautiful  climates the scenery is amazing the soil  is fertile so a lot of populations in  history have gotten drawn to these  active volcanoes I personally would not  live on the foothills of an active  volcano